Wehaveavoicemailnumber,thatnumberis2192,DavidPhereisavoicemail,fromsomeone
veryclearlyowningtheLibsbecauseofBernie'shypocrisy.Takealistenaday.Thisisagymfor
ISIS.Justwannasaythat,acommunistpartySandersahypocritehefliesonprivatejets,buthe
talksaboutallthiscarbonemissionsareontopofthat.
IneverhearI'mliking.
Youhaveacreatorrightthere,wearewearingthesecanclosealltheseschoolsmaypickbutlike
whetheryouagainstslavery,howcanyouagainstslavery?Andthen,we'recottonclose.
Youshouldbewearinganything.
Yeah,listen,Idon'tknowanythingaboutAbrahamLincoln'sslave­pickedcotton,clothes.WhatI
03/04/20 Page15of17
davidpakmanshow­2020­03­03­commercialfree
cantellyouaboutBernieSandersiswhatIcareaboutispolicy.Idon'tcareifacandidateisrichor
poor,apriori.WhatIcareaboutis,whataretheirpoliciesgoingtodofortheaverageperson,if
BernieSanderswereregularly,flyingonaprivatejetIthinkthattherewouldbeacritiqueinthere.
Ofcourse,thispersonthrowinginBernie'saCommunistandhefliesonprivatejets.Bernieis
obviouslynotacommunist.MyunderstandingisBerniefluonaprivatejetafewtimesbecauseof
theschedulingrequirementsaroundtheSenateImpeachmenttrial,ofDonaldTrump,andpossibly
somesortoflastminutecampaignthingsthataregoingonbytheway,everypresidentliesona
privatejet.
Eventuallya...Andtherewouldbe...
Arewegoingtosaythatnopresidentshoulddothateither?IknowthattheMexicanPresidentfor
sometimewasactuallyflyingaflatfinecommercial.
Thepracticalitiesofit.
Listen,ifBernieifBerniedoesn'tannounceAirForceOneisPresidentandcontinuestoflyAir
ForceOne,butheactuallyfixesourtaxsystemandimproveshealthcareandmakeeducationmore
accessibletopeople.Idon'tcareaboutflyingonAirForceOne,Iknowprivatejetsareabsolutely
destructiveonaperpassengerbasistotheenvironmentthereisnodoubtaboutit.I'mwithyouon
that,butthat'snotwhatthispersonistalkingabout.Thispersonisjustlookingtoattackpeople.I
careaboutpolicyandIsupportpeopleonthebasisofthepoliciesthattheyproposed.Thisislike...
ButBernie'sthreehouses,andwedealtwiththatacoupleofweeksago.Comeon,let'sfocuson
policy.
We'vegotagreatbonusforyoutoday,JoinUsthelastpre­SuperTuesday,bonustojoinPacman
dotcomorpatreondotcom,DavidPacmanshowtogetinstantaccesstothatbonusshow.We'll
talkaboutthenewObamaCarecasebeforetheSupremeCourtwilltalkabouthowChina'sair
pollutionhasdroppedduringthevirusquarantineandwewilltalkaboutTrump,defending
continuingtoholdrallies,asthevirusspread.
Thosestoriesandmoretoday,includingmymyvotedstorycomingupaswell.
TheDavidpackmen,sheatDavidpackmentocome.